der begriff wieder raus an sich schon
komisch im fußballbereich weil es eben
so in der öffentlichkeit
es ist ein bisschen negativ behaftet man
sagt er hat diesen weg noch tasche ihres
mannes ist ja bei ihnen jetzt auch nicht
mehr nur der fall
[Musik]
ein
bei ihm passt teils teils ich glaube sie
spielt gerne mit diesem klischee weil
sie genau weiß dass viele einfach da
auch nicht umzupolen sind und hier war
denkweise heute selbstständig macht mein
eigenes geld ja das will doch keiner
hören wir wollen noch hören dass die
spieler vorbilder klare linie
spielaufbau das will ich auch erstmal so
beibehalten
er soll ich bloß noch ein paar jahre
spielen und habe ich ja gar keinen job
mehr da habe ich mir immer gedacht so
hey was haben die gegen die ich aber
mittlerweile habe ich auch gelernt und
es ist einfach der neid malerin hat bei
mir kommentiert da nichts anderes tun
als sport zu machen meine sachen gepackt
ist ja auch so wenn man der hat jetzt
mit verstand man kann halt ob wir fotos
auch nicht immer dieselben sachen an
haben das dann ja auch langweilig dann
gehen wir auch irgendwann einfach so weg
also ist jetzt nicht so dass ich nur
dafür lebe die zufrieden zu stellen aber
klar macht einen das als frau sowieso
schon spaß zu shoppen also ich glaube
kann jede frau bestätigen
[Musik]